[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
so
uh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
um
[Music]
[Music]
oh
hello everyone my name is jacob
sebastian and welcome to this exciting
show
we are going to be getting an exclusive
first look at the brand new video game
dedicated to hot wheels a certifiable
american legend that has played such an
integral role in the lives of
generations all around the world through
childhood
and beyond we've been given the
opportunity to preview some gameplay and
we'll be talking to the developers
themselves to find out about some of the
most exciting features
of this highly anticipated video game at
the end we will have a q a session so i
invite you to start posting your
questions in chat
we have with us today ricardo bracino vp
global franchise marketing from mattel
hi diego thank you very much for having
me and and hi to all the hot wheels fans
out there
we're looking forward to see everything
about hot wheels unleashed
thank you ricardo now could you please
tell us more about the hot wheels brand
and its legacy
yes of course you know hot wheels has
been around since 1968 and since 1968
it's been a reflection of car culture
and has
influenced our culture in fact you know
everyone's first car
is a hot wheel so now we have an
incredible community of fans that are
you know
huge fans of the brand that that truly
display what what hot wheels is about
and how it's all about the challenger
spirit
that idea of never giving up trying and
failing and repeating and repeating and
repeating and repeating the idea that
that of course it's all about winning
because we're all about competition but
the journey to the win is almost as
important to the
than the win itself um so again everyone
who's into cars today it's into hot
wheels and
you know the brand's bigger than it's
ever been and uh
and we're looking forward and excited to
see kind of the next chapter of the
brand
uh in video gaming hot wheels is an
incredible phenomenon
what does hot wheels mean to you well
you know
hot was this almost a a dream come true
to me and
you know i've been working on the brand
for almost a decade and before that i
was a fan as a kid
much like all of our fans out there and
uh you know
it's it's it represents passion for
automotive
passion for everything for wheels uh
passion for speed
but also passion for kind of what the
brand stands for or
or challenge or spirit and and for the
the little piece in everyone's heart
that that people have
about about hotwood you know it hot
wheels reminds people
of fun things of what's exciting and you
know
all those positive experiences and
finally the sense of community that hot
wheels represent you know
community as a kid and as you share your
play experience with you with your
friends
uh but also community as an automotive
uh as an automotive community and you
know what cars represent
and how hot wheels is a common
an area of commonality for anyone who's
into cars and also for anyone who's into
collecting hot wheels so we have a
giant worldwide family of fans that
truly care about hot wheels
and that we want to celebrate and again
with this amazing hot wheels and lynch
game
i know that they're all want to be part
of it and you know
take advantage of one new way to
interact and participate in the hot
wheels brand
we're all here to see the very first
gameplay of hot wheels unleashed what do
you expect from it
this is going to be really really fun uh
because this is going to be
a video game like no other
for the first time we're going to get to
see what it feels like
and experiment firsthand what what it's
like to almost be shrunken down to
toy side toy size and pretend that we're
in
one hot wheels like one hot with zaika's
cars
driving around the track uh
we're gonna see a lot of cool hot wheels
tracks just like we all used to have in
our childhoods in our in our homes
but also a ton of speed a ton of racing
drifting
jumping stunting so i think it's gonna
be really fun
i've seen seen some things here and
there and it's looking amazing
i cannot wait to play the game because
i'm sure it's gonna be incredibly fun
well thank you ricardo for joining us on
the show and see you on track
thank you diego and thanks to all the
fans out there that are tuning in
see everyone on the track and see who
comes in first fans have been clamoring
for a video game that would live up to
the hall wheels legend for rages and
finally the wait is about to end
we have here two developers from
milestone hq in milan
the calico lady executive producer and
milestone and federico cardini
lead game designer for hot wheels
unleashed hey guys how are you doing
i'd like to ask you the same question as
to recorder from mattel what does hot
wheels mean to you
hello everyone i'm very happy to be here
today
well for me hot wheels is collecting i'm
a collector i love
race cars road cars sports cars
muscle cars and so i'm completely aware
that there's something for everyone
in this big universe of hot wheels but
that's what i like
and today we'll see a pre-alpha build
that's still in development
many things are going to change but we
are eager to show you the game
instead what about you what do you think
federico about
the hot wheels world well michele
i think that i'm more towards the
creativity side of the hot wheels brand
i like the hot wheels originals and you
know all those outlandish design with
monsters and uh kind of uh
special cars that you cannot see
everywhere else let's start with you
mikhail
tell us briefly about the game you know
what type of game it is where we can
play it and
who is it for hot wheels unleashed is a
very fast
paced and energetic arcade racer it's
going to be out
on all the consoles and on pc
and it's a game that's very easy to pick
up
but then you'll discover there's a lot
to master in the game you'll find
all the the real hot wheels cars but
also
special parts the orange trucks and we
invented also some special parts to play
with
to play with because you can also create
your own trucks
so you'll be able to band reality in
fact you'll be able to create
things that you cannot have in real life
and that's the fun part of the game
hey federico i can't wait to talk about
cars
which hot wheels vehicles will we be
able to race with will there be a fixed
number of models in the game
or will new ones become available over
time i don't want to spoil
too much but i have to say that there
are more than 60 cars
inside the game and they are of course
taken from the
hot wheels ward so you will surely find
something
that you like and fits your taste and i
have to say that
cars are actually identical to reality
we really took
an incredibly detailed approach to
reproducing them so as you can see
you can notice the mold lines and the
fingerprints
and all those characteristics that
really make them feel
like they are out from your collection
and
of course every vehicle has its own
personality and we
have taken these and put it into the
game by using a different set of
style for each of these and i would like
to point out that
you will surely find something that you
like
and every single car is competitive so
don't worry and just pick what you love
i have to say that this has been the
part that we love the most
i'm making this game because we selected
every single vehicle by hand
depending on its personality his style
and even its history i have to say
now in this specific demo you are only
gonna see
six vehicles and there are 12 opponents
on the track so you will see some
duplicates but this will not be the case
in the final title because i don't want
to go into much details
in order to not spoil any surprises but
we have more than 60 vehicles
in the game and many more will come
after launch
wow more than 60 cars that's awesome
in the real world some models are
extremely rare and hard to find
will it be the same in the game of
course each car has a rarity
and this gravity represents its place
inside the game
there is a rarity system that we are
going to explain in the future
and that really brings out the spirit of
collecting
various art with vehicles and before
we go into much details for this i
actually would like to explain
a little bit how you are gonna obtain
vehicles inside the game
so there are various different game
modes in which you can play
and the rewards that you will get for
from these game modes
are actually something that you can use
in order to obtain
new vehicles and sometimes when we feel
generous
we might even want to give you for free
some vehicles and of course in order to
be
extremely faithful to the brand which is
a theme that
really encompasses the entire game
i'm sure that you will love searching
for those spatula cars you know those
super treasure ants wow super treasure
hunts hot wheels fans will definitely
love it
and can we also customize the models to
make them more unique
of course as fan of the brand we
recognize the fact that sometimes
casting new castings come out each year
but they may have a
different delivery from the here before
and maybe your favorite livery is not
inside the game
so we decided to give you a livery
editor an extremely powerful delivery
editor
where you can actually create your
hotwheels exactly as you want them
and of course if you are the creative
type you can upload those deliveries
online
and if you don't want to go through the
article of you know
customizing a vehicle you can just
search for the vehicles and deliveries
that have been uploaded
and download them apply them to your
collection
and race with them as if you did them
now back to you mchaley please tell us
more about the different game modes
well the heart of the game is the career
mode that's lengthy
uh with several events with different
difficulties
and also something special the boss
fights
well something unique you've never heard
about in a racing game but yes we have
boss fights
and we have multiplayer both online
obviously
but also two players split screen you
can play on the coach with
uh with your friends with your family
that's an important part
because we think this game suits
perfectly to this
and you'll be able to also play the
tracks
you have created in the editor so i
think
that's a very wide and complete package
i can't wait to play it now can you
reveal any more details or features
regarding the gameplay mechanics
well the gameplay is based heavily on
drifting and boosting
drifting is a lot of fun because it
helps him to close the corners
and to keep up the speed but also has a
second use
it charges the boost every car has a
different setup of boost
like slots intensity and when you charge
the boost
you'll have to know when to use it
wisely because
you can use it to get out of the corner
faster you can use it
to overtake at the very last moment the
last car in the final lap
but also you can use it to try to kick
the cars out of the truck
you can use it to be sure to close the
loop and
there's a lot of situations where you
have to know where not to use it
not to jump off the truck so knowing the
trucks
is also very important there are many
different special pieces
around the trucks that interact with you
like the
accelerating strips that give you a
slight speed kick
so you have to know where they are and
to manage this speed boost you can get
there are many other things like this
spider we can see
it throws you some spider webs and you
can boost through in order to
skip them or try to avoid them there are
many different pieces more than 20
in the game so it's going to be very
lively from
the start to the checkered flag you can
also fall out of the truck and you have
to respawn or maybe sometimes you can
find an
alternate route that gets you back into
the truck so
know the tracks know the dynamics and
there's going to be
a lot of action throughout the race hall
wheels is not only about cars
it's also about the incredible tracks
you can race on how does this aspect
feature in the game
when we were deciding where to locate
our game we were talking to ourselves
and saying well
where would we like to actually go play
with our hot wheels
sets so we selected some environments
that
each have their own personality like
a big open space or different
levels an incredible amount of
verticality
and each one of these environments has
its special characteristics
that kind of determine how you want to
build your trucks so as you can see
inside the garage
we have a lot of open space and the
trucks are kind of
open wide and they encompass a good part
of the environment and sometimes
since we are not forced to actually stay
on the truck pieces
for example here you can see the truck
growing inside
the old air conditioning system
and really where you want to go into the
environment
and the elements that you want to
interact with
are actually completely up to you and
there is also a special environment in
the game
it's what we call the player's home base
you see this environment is a little bit
different from the others because
there is actually a certain level of
customization involved with it
and i think we are gonna go into more
details with these uh
in a future video you see since we are
talking about content and we want to be
a hundred percent
transparent with you um i'm pleased to
say that we will have more than 40
trucks
at day one and six different
environments
we also have quite the hefty
you know future plan for this game and a
lot of new content coming your way so in
order to know more
just follow our social media channels in
the coming months
i'm sure you won't be disappointed we'll
do for sure federico now one last
question for you mikaylee
are there any plans for players to be
able to create their own tracks using
the original hot wheels pieces
yes there's going to be a truck editor
in the game
and the big news is that is the very
same editor
that the designers are using to create
the tracks you've seen and you see
in the next months so everything they
can do
you'll be able to do on your own to
create your own tracks
i mean twisting bending
stretching the parts adding loops adding
special parts
everything they do you'll be able to do
the same
to play them online to play them in
split screen
so it's going to be a very very powerful
tool
very easy to use and you're going to
have a lot of fun with it
and bear in mind that everything we've
seen is in pre-alpha stage
so everything is still in development
there are many things that will
unveil in the next months so there's a
lot to see
lots of developments and many news in
the next
months to come thank you michael i know
you guys have a special surprise
for the community now can you tell us
what it is yes we kept it for last and
it's the premiere of the gameplay
trailer
so enjoy it and i hope you like it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
it's incredible how the dev team has
managed not only to bring the vehicles
and the entire hot wheels universe to
pulsating life
but also to take advantage of the latest
developments and technology to bring us
an incredible gaming experience
this is really taking the concert to the
next level and as a keen gamer
i can't wait to get my hands on it and i
bet that you are as excited
as i am let's fuel our hype even more by
having a look at how incredibly fun
hot wheels unleashed is going to be
check out these reactions from some very
lucky creators who had the chance to
already put their hands on the game
let's go ahead and shrink ourselves down
to hot wheels size
green flames here we go first quarter
those crossover points that's amazing oh
look at that see that was smooth that's
what you want
full gas full gas full boost all the way
through right here
[Music]
there we go just got to get it right as
getting it out of the corner that works
perfect
boost out of the corner as well push it
up to sixth place final lap
let's do this come on this plays so
nicely this is definitely something i
think we're the track editor as well
people are gonna have
so much fun with this game odium oh no
i've been smashed i'm gonna go
[Music]
now that you have seen the video game
and the reactions of those who have the
chance to play with it
time to go back to the developers to
answer your questions from the milestone
hq in mls
well that's all from me for now hope to
catch you online as soon as the game
drops and i'm looking forward to
challenging you on track
go fast go hot wheels
hello welcome back we are here i hope
you enjoyed so far
we're here to answer your questions so
uh
come and ask some more there are already
some
uh let me read through um
ignacio asks there will be cross play
okay so cross play is something
extremely hard for us as a developer it
has quite a
series of challenges we are looking into
it
now especially on the cross generation
uh crossplay uh not uh
uh we are not looking at cross platform
as of now yeah it means
like playstation 4 against players five
xbox
series x against the old one yeah
exactly
uh we were working on it yes it's a very
complex matter and
we're we our r d department is working
hard on this
exactly we'll look into it do not expect
it at day one
i would say but it's something you are
looking at
oh then uh can we customize gameplay
cameras we've always seen the
third person camera is there anything
else or why
are we working with this kind of camera
it is something that we considered
during development you know having
different cameras is something that
you see quite a lot of games do but uh
in
this game there are a lot of situations
that are quite extreme
like going upside down or having uh
looping or
yeah or looping around extreme changes
of that
poses quite the challenge and not from a
technical standpoint but more from a
game player's
perspective because you have
difficulties following what everything
that is happening in the race with such
a variety of situations so we are
focusing
around you yeah seeing it far to
understand what's going on
yeah and uh so uh as of now we're
focusing on
the gameplay camera that you've seen in
the gameplay
oh then
uh carson lane up will be uh the 2021
only or
there will be some uh other cars from
the past
asks russell 85. so
while i can't go into many videos for
this
i can assure you that you will not see
only cars from
2021 but uh we've done our research
and we have gone uh in the past to
search for the best authorities
available
yeah we are all hot with lovers so
there's a lot to dig there's a lot to
discover
absolutely we are we are going got some
aces
you know going only for the 21 lineup
will be a disservice in my opinion
okay uh then uh a question that i see
quite often
uh about the accelerary acceleracers
cause
there will be anything about this many
of you are asking
so we're listening to your feedback guys
uh
i can't of course anticipate anything uh
but we are working on it i mean we are
we have seen what you want
we know what you want and uh keep an eye
out keep an eye out yeah
everybody seems to be asking this uh
absolutely one way or the other
and uh we know we know we know very well
uh then uh
do we race only on orange truck pieces
or is there anything else
well that's that's that's a clever one
akim
yes this is this is actually one of my
favorite questions because
i really love our truck editor and uh i
can assure you that it has been built
with them
an incredible amount of customization in
mind so you are
not forced to go only on
orange track pieces uh you can actually
when you use the track piece you can
actually customize it
a little bit even in color yeah there
are variations
yes there are variations you can have
very wide
parts of the truck where you don't will
actually go on on the
exactly on the truck pieces but you can
wander around use the environment yeah
where you can use the environment that's
that's one of the strong points
exactly and also you actually have two
different type of races you might have
catch uh
a glimpse of it in the gameplay uh but
there are rules
there are both circuits and the
point-to-point
tracks and you can build whatever you
want you make more
yeah and usually there's something very
flashy going on
in this case absolutely ah then
frenzy asks can we customize
environments
so not all of them there is one
environment that is customizable
we kind of consider it to be the home
base of the player
and you have the quite a degree of
customization involved in it we are
going to show it uh
later and um i think it would be
satisfied because you will be able to
express uh
your style with this besides the editing
facilities that absolutely that there's
plenty of options yes yeah
oh then what kind of dlc is expecting in
the future just cars or
new environments trucks species or
anything else
well there's a lot yeah there is
actually a lot
yes um first thing first we have
both free and premium dlcs
uh planned and there are different types
of content actually because we are going
to cover a lot of content that
with our dlcs from vehicles to new truck
pieces
and also what we call full expansion
sets that
is something that you're going to see
into the future but contain
quite a lot of new content for the game
yes it is to keep the game alive
i have several contents some small some
free
some something bigger you know to make
the game
very very long life beyond the day one
and more yes then
will be the new cars making
their debut in hot wheels unleashed asks
aphazad ninja
well there are various 2021 vehicles
um i don't want to go into much details
for this because we might ruin the
surprise
but there's a lot of things we cannot
cover even if we would like because
uh much of the contents will be unveiled
later on so
keep following us on our social media
because there's
going to be a lot to see and to hear and
to
enjoy but yeah yeah yeah
i wonder how the drifting system works
if
it has one yes it has one sma g96
so the difference is actually quite
complex our drifty system
is based on you know the
extreme the knowledge that uh
milestone has gained over the years
working on simulation titles
and um it's actually all based on the
breaking
so you break in order to start the drift
but then you are quite free to control
it during the actual
that seems quite hard while we speak but
in fact it's very easy oh
it's super easy absolutely flat on with
the with the accelerator
absolutely you slam the brakes you turn
and you start drifting
and while you drift you still have
control over and you can break
yes you can boost and then you you
understand you can
chain behaviors like you drift while you
hit an accelerator pad that gives you a
boost
absolutely and then you keep drifting
even faster and while you boost
you uh well you drift you you gain some
more boost
absolutely so it's it's about where you
know where to drift where
nowhere you boost so i know it's a
classic but you know
it's the classic um easy to learn to
learn and the hard to master this was
the approach without
very physical it's not scripted it's
very physical so the things that are
going on sometimes are very frantic
but in a good way absolutely you're you
feel in control even if things
seem to be very very uh on fire on the
screen yeah
ah then um
there will be loot boxes uh well
absolutely no
no absolutely no loot boxes in this game
uh when you are going to you know when
there are dlcs
uh what you see is what you get your we
do not use
any loot boxes system or anything like
that there is a there are some
some systems in the game where there is
some randomness involved
but not with real where real money
is required there are many ways to
unlock the cars and yes
absolutely is self-contained into the
game so
you you won't have to pay for for loot
boxes absolutely
what what their dlc's and everything but
not loot boxes
uh i don't know if there's any other
question from
our players so far
well seems like our time is over so uh
thank you for watching
i hope you enjoyed the the footage
you've seen the gameplay
i hope you enjoyed what you've seen and
and the answers we try to to give you
keep following keep following our social
media because there's a lot to discover
there's a
number of new exciting announcements
over the new
uh the next month so a lot to discover
and to understand about this exciting
game because
we are very excited we would have liked
to tell you more
but there's we have to keep some
surprises for later
absolutely thank you so far uh
good night and thank you all goodbye
[Music]
you